kudos to west career technical academy  they have a lot to celebrate the schools  we the people group recently won first  place in the state competition and  they're now headed for the finals in  washington d.c now the focus of the  group is a deep dive into the  constitution and demonstrates students  knowledge from the articles of  confederation to present-day history the  group's teachers tell us this is a big  opportunity that hasn't happened in 23  years  just the fact that  we're competing i i tell everyone don't  don't count us out because  we're coming and we're coming in strong  14 students are now headed to washington  dc that competition is going to happen  in april the group is hoping to raise  twenty thousand dollars in order to fund  that trip if you would like to help you  can check out our website at eight  newsnow dot com